here yeah
uh we're live all right we are live uh
podcast episode number 26 we have a
special guest here today
if you look at this picture here this is
very important for some of you guys that
came with us early
that picture right there is a man with a
red shirt on
steve murphy okay the show narcos on
netflix the man below
is pablo escobar and our guest today is
my friend
steve murphy steve it's good to see you
again you as well patrick thanks for
having me back and obviously
tom uh will be with us me tom and steve
so guys
tom we got a girl steve today wow on on
what happened with pablo escobar what's
going on with oregon we got to learn
from steve
and i think the last time uh steve when
you were a guest
we did an interview on pablo escobar
right when narcos was uh still being you
know going around it was a talk of town
and i think that's got over 3 million
views and what's exciting is today
steve's uh uh uh paperback book
man hunters comes out today how we took
down the
how we took down pablo escobar we're
gonna have a good time going into that
um but prior to that let me kind of
preface some of the topics we got let's
talk about some of the topics we got
today
business predatory and opportunistic
southwest airlines seizes the moment
as rival struggles okay we'll talk about
what's going on over there uh who is the
modern-day pablo escobar
uh is it rafa caro quintero is it el
chapo is it somebody else we will see
what
steve has to say about that elon musk's
tesla joining the s p
500 spacex launching four astronauts to
the international space station
and a milestone for countries commercial
space ambitions hbo max is coming
uh uh to amazon devices which i'm
curious to know what you think about
that by the way
tom i'm actually really curious what
what kind of a difference is that going
to make sure
vista outdoors reports ammunition
backlog over a billion dollars
i want to hear what uh steve's got to
say about it and a couple clips with
steve
sidney powell if you guys been following
that and then nancy pelosi
uh begging not pleading begging with
house stamps to not take jobs on biden
cabinet
in fear of losing majority trump march
in washington biden charity spent on
research
3.7 million on salary zero on research
which
i don't know if that's a good idea to do
that way warren urges biden to bypass
congress and cancel student loan debt
hillary clinton to be added on
ambassador as a u.n assyrian is being
attacked by turks maybe we can get into
that a little bit
and then legalizing drugs across the
level oregon votes to decriminalize all
drugs curfews coming to la
newsom saying considering statewide the
uh curfew dominion voting system the
company at the center of michigan and
georgia voting glitches
uh and then 300 000 people left new york
but prior to us getting to
any of these topics steve you're
somebody that you probably follow the
current event and what's taking place
what are your thoughts what everything's
going on since the last time you and i
met
we've had coronavirus we've had
protesting we've had riots we've had
you know uh a bunch of things going on
with
election you know divided america today
what are your thoughts with the current
state we have in
america well the two biggest topics you
see now is the election and the
coronavirus
and i'll be honest with you i'm sick of
both of them the i live in the dc area
and it's our news media is just
dominated by what's going on there
i think here in our country we're
probably divided more now than we ever
have been since the civil war
it's ridiculous what's going on we're
still americans you can still have
differences of opinion
that doesn't make you an enemy you know
you don't have to go into a fight i'm a
big proponent of the first amendment i'm
a
proponent of all the amendments but the
right to speech
i like it that doesn't give you the
right to violence to
commit destruction robberies assault
other people
so there's got to be some control over
that you know i love it that one party
preaches or presents itself to be the
peaceful party but the truth is
i'm not seeing and not to get too
political here because i try to stay
apolitical but
you see one party marches and you don't
see a lot of violence
the other one business owners had to
board up their shops before
the announcement the election results
were announced
so it's it's a double-edged sword now if
you talk to that particular party i'm
sure they'll say oh it's antifa or
that's the other groups
that are just there to commit violence
which is possible
but somebody's funding them right you
know i asked
i asked the uh who was we had a couple
friends here in town from michigan they
were here yesterday we spent three hours
with them
good people good business people and i
asked the question i said
what happens if sydney powell is right
okay sidney powell's not a lightweight
attorney i think we would all
agree with that if you know you know
sydney powell sydney powell is
trump's current attorney who represented
i believe michael flynn yeah
and she is former prosecutor for the
feds yeah
she's as she's as strong as any of these
guys can be about me
can you pull up the video on sydney pal
i don't know which one you have by the
way i'm just curious to know which one
you got up there's one video
is this the one sydney pound uh you
wanna
you wanna put it on this is from sunday
you wanna put it on 1.5 you want to put
on 1.5 go to speed 1.5 and maybe speed
it up a little bit
yeah if you want to put the 2 000
jurisdictions in 30 states according to
experts if one site has a flaw
other sites are likely to as well which
is why texas rejected using dominion
software three times
raising concerns that the system was not
safe from fraudulent or unauthorized
manipulation that's troubling giving we
already know that at least two software
glitches in georgia and michigan
occurred on election night attorney
cindy powell is leading the charge
against dominion and she says she has
enough evidence of fraud to launch a
massive criminal investigation sydney
thanks very much for being here we
appreciate your time this morning i want
to get right into it we just heard about
the software uh made by smartmatic from
rudy and i want to get your take on what
you report what you and i spoke about
a gentleman named peter neffinger tell
me how he fits into all of this
yes well he is listed as it's former
admiral peter neffenger a retired
admiral peter neffinger he is president
and on the board of directors of
smartmatic and it just so happens he's
on
mr biden's presidential transition team
that's going to be non-existent
because we're fixing to overturn the
results of the election in multiple
states
and president trump won by not just
hundreds of thousands of
votes but by millions of votes that were
shifted by this software that was
designed expressly for that purpose
we have sworn witness testimony of why
the software was designed it was
designed to rig elections
he was fully briefed on it he saw it
happen in other countries it was
exported internationally for profit
by the people that are behind smartmatic
and dominion
they did this on purpose it was
calculated they've done it before we
have evidence from 2016 in california
we have so much evidence i feel like
it's coming in through a fire hose okay
pause right now wow
i think so if you haven't watched it by
the way then i watched stelter this
morning on cnn
uh is it is that that's his name stelter
is that the uh
you know what i'm talking about right
yeah i know who you're talking type in
stelter cnn and i'm watching him this
morning
just to kind of see what both sides are
saying okay stelter i believe it's
uh cnn uh cnn yeah type that
and just that's fine just kai what are
you doing just that's good
uh and it's gotta yeah right there press
on the first one click on the first one
fox news has never had this much
competition as they are today et cetera
et cetera and then it's explaining the
fact that aon you know newsmax
all these guys are competing with them
and demand the problem the
disinformation supply and demand so
on this section is over even though
president trump is still in denial
right there so in this section he is
saying
everything everybody else is saying is
disinformation
all the stuff that we're hearing about
dominion is disinformation sydney powell
on the other side is saying no this is
real we have proof
and not a little bit of proof but we
have a lot of proof right here's my
question for both of you guys
let's say let's just play this real
quick right now america's peaceful
there's nothing going on in the streets
okay i went to
barnes and noble the other day to buy a
few books for my kids i saw time
magazine
not president-elect 46th president
it's official it's official it didn't
say president-elect on the cover of joe
biden's president
46 right say there's three things
that'll happen
one this goes away it is biden's the
president number two
it continues and uh you know biden
becomes president maybe there's a
negotiation for some other stuff
and you know the whole pardon thing
we're not gonna bother you let us just
go and we'll concede you know i'll shall
concede okay
but number three if powell is right if
what powell is saying is right
if there is voter fraud at the level
where it got
chavez elected it got maduro elected
where he can
switch the votes without anybody knowing
about it if it
flips let's go to the if it flips you're
in that world
if it flips as ugly as the last year two
years have been with protesting and
right
if it flips what happens to america uh
it's gonna be so bad
i mean i'm not even sugarcoating you
know i'm the most optimistic person
anybody knows
uh you asked me eight ten twelve two
years ago eight ten twelve months two
years ago
i would never think it would be possible
for us to be in the situation that we're
in right now
and it gets worse every day all right
steve you had mentioned the fact that
hey we're pretty divided right now and
you know we're still americans i don't
feel that way
the the the divisiveness is so strong so
pat what would happen
they've already got a plan for it one
side i'm sure they do
um their soldiers they're foot soldiers
antifa whoever it is on the street
they've got a plan for that
they're organized they're organized in
every city there isn't
one big national block of antifa they're
in every city they're
card carrying members in some of these
cities that's why you seem so organized
in a portland
and in seattle in places like this and
they can mobilize quickly
so if number three happened it would be
the military would have to be involved
right here in the united states in my
opinion
it would be so bad now what is holding
her back from unloading some of this
information
because she her reputation is at stake
i mean this is the biggest thing she's
ever been involved in right a lot of
people are knowing cindy powell
because of her involvement with this i'm
ready for the information to start
coming out she implied on sunday morning
that it might start happening this week
i mean when you start saying the
information is coming in through a fire
hose
firing it's at some point we have to see
some of this are they being so careful
and meticulous knowing that things are
so volatile it's like a powder keg
it'll go off once this comes out i don't
know but we got to start seeing the
evidence
by the end of the week have to what do
you think will happen stephen i agree if
you've got the evidence put it on the
table
you know let's get through this let's
get over this let's make a final
decision
let's keep stop keeping the entire
united states disrupted
by what's going on if there's evidence
let's see it don't just sit around and
talk about it
but what do you think will happen if the
evidence shows and trump stays as
president oh it's going to be violent
the chaos is going to be worse than it
has been i think you know
the one side doesn't want to give up
look at the last four years of his
administration i mean they they
took him for impeachment and lost
you know so imagine being the the most
powerful
person in the world and you can't get
your job done effectively
because of all these distractions they
keep throwing at you yeah and the whole
narrative will be that he stole it
right that they are so ready for this i
think
i think it gets really bad if that were
to happen and you almost wonder if
sometimes
if trump in the back of his mind is
thinking man this is what would happen
maybe i'm better off to slide away on
this one but i think he'd start
campaigning day one for 2024.
i literally think he would be a
four-year campaigner for the next job
he'd be doing rallies every week
i think i think he loves it why is that
why because i think he feels he's the
face of the republican party right now
and the conservatives
and i think he looks at himself as a
savior and i don't mean that in a
in a way that you know he thinks he's
god or something but i think he sees a
real tipping point here in the country
right now
someone has to step forward and be the
face of it and he's
people rallied to him so if he is
officially out
i think he declares a candidacy for 2024
i remember when obama
you know announced it caught a lot of
people off guard he started campaigning
the beginning of 2007
which is a pretty long time i remember
him you know making appearances and
doing speeches that's a long time to
campaign i think trump would double that
i think he would be campaigning for four
years literally
what's the outcome though for him to win
to make sure that he wins in 2024
maybe to help flip the house in two
years to get some momentum just going on
the republican side
for him to win in 2024 meaning what does
that mean for him to win 20 president
he's going to run for president again
you're thinking no no i'm saying he
loses
okay he loses no if he loses i i think
i think he starts campaigning right away
and runs again yeah i
i uh um uh i hope we're wrong with
what's gonna happen if he does i mean
the reality of it is the chances of him
winning have you been studying a lot
with what's going on with
sydney powell dominion have you looked
at a lot of that stuff with the software
and not really no
okay you've been following yourself what
are your chances right now from last
week you said
a different percentage 28 has it changed
or are you about the same number i'm
going to stay the same i'm going to say
like in the low 30s i'm going to say
it was 28 but it went up a little bit
just because of her confidence yeah
she's sitting on something they know
something but but she comes out now what
what are the laws what are the
regulations
how is the court going to handle that i
mean that's the part where we don't know
what's going to happen right the reality
is
what is the timeline you got to middle
december by the way if you
watch cnn if you watch msnbc they are
convinced 100 trump is
gone biden's the president if you watch
newsmax
if you watch aon if you watch can't say
fox but if you watch those two
they're fully convinced that trump is
winning and they have something here
right
it's it's for me it's hard to sit in the
middle and say i don't really know
what's gonna happen right now because
if they are right you know everything
about a strategist is what if this
happens we do this if that happens we do
this if that happens we pivot here
i tell you what though if he does come
in shock
i mean you realize what happens to the
media if the last four years he marketed
fake news at the level that he did and
he wins you know what he's gonna do next
four years
he's gonna trash these guys in ways
that's never happened before and they're
gonna make a fool out of themselves
if he wins but flip it let me flip it
for you yeah flip it for you
say he loses okay okay biden wins if he
loses
biden wins um
his reaction how is he going to react if
he loses after dragging it out for one
week
because if you drag it out this long and
you lose
it's not a pretty scene right there so
what do you think is going to happen he
stays with the same narrative that he
had it taken away from him that he
officially won that he had more votes
but for the good of the country he's
gonna step aside so i think that's how
he would handle it um he'll never get
off the fact that
he thinks he won this and you know what
presidents just like they know what's
going on
as you do um you know they get their
intelligence reports every day he knows
things that are going on in iran and
afghanistan and china right now that
we'll never know we have no clue clearly
he has some information about what
happened here but there might not be
anything
he could do about it by the end of this
week
yeah i'm curious myself what do you
think well
one i i'm really upset because i think
the rest of the world is just sitting
back laughing at us
you know i think we've become the
worldwide joke i think we're losing our
prominence in the
in the world view as being the leading
country in the entire world
because of things like this um
and to be just quite honest i think it's
sad that the two best candidates we
could come up with were who we had to
choose from not just this election but
the last election as well
i mean hillary and trump and trump and
biden right
and and you know i got to be honest with
you i used to uh
when biden was in his as the vice
president i heard him speak to a law
enforcement group the international
association of chiefs of police
and i liked everything he said you know
and i'm a very conservative type person
and he wasn't but
he came across a very pro law
enforcement check it now
he's not pro in law enforcement now have
you heard anything about all the police
officers that are being killed in the
line of duty here in the united states
right now
the numbers are going up the ambush is
the the unprovoked attacks
and what's the media doing the media
highlights every
police officer involved shooting not
waiting to the for the facts they try to
inflame
every you know the listeners which
that's what kills me about the media as
well
yeah you tell me what the story is what
the facts are let me decide what i think
is right and wrong don't tell me what
i'm supposed to believe
but that ship has sailed the media is no
longer that anymore i mean if you're
looking to get
news and information and something on
bot it will never happen again
i mean they're businesses that's all
they are what is the price what is the
price
of not showing anything good that cops
do
meaning if it's only showing things they
do bad and they don't show anything good
that cops to what's the consequences
what's what's the results
more hatred of the cops you know and
especially playing up with something
that does happen when someone gets shot
by a cop right and
immediately the call is for violence in
those cities and it goes out and they
just perpetuate it you know i can just
speak from experience
um like on our news site vtpost.com
like you if i wanted to find a picture
you know and go to some of these news
services and find a photo
from a riot in portland or maybe
something that happened in minneapolis
if we needed it
they were trying to you know the city
council minneapolis had to have an
emergency meeting
and and get 500 000 to bring in more
cops because their defunding thing
wasn't working and their cities out of
control
i can't even find the images because
they won't even allow you to search
for riot or protest or thing like it's
all
unrest so the you just see it on
every layer on every level and
you know we talked about violence if
this thing were to uh
if trump were somehow able to flip this
thing it would be stoked by the media
they would be the ones almost
encouraging it and
championing the people that are out
there protesting
right so it's interesting steve you look
at the media when it's a slow news day
what do they do they sensationalize the
weather they sensationalize the traffic
patterns whatever the
you know i mean anything to explode a
story way out of proportion
just tell us the facts and let us decide
that's one of the things how we're gonna
you know
probably not have our speaking business
and when we do conferences the last
thing we leave the audience with is
don't let other people tell you what to
think you know when there's a story that
happens you do your research and you
make a decision
don't listen to other people just simply
because they're willing to voice their
opinions
yeah and it you know and with
coronavirus because they're tied in
because everything is about fear right
now
all right there's a fundamental effort i
think just to get people
to change this country and they're going
to do it with fear so it's the numbers
that they throw at us every single day
with coronavirus
i think there will be a point literally
i think it'll come very very soon
people say they don't trust the media or
they don't watch it's clearly they still
get numbers but they're
speaking to you know themselves cnn
msnbc
they're speaking to the liberal elite
the on the on the coasts essentially
they disregard everybody in the middle
of the country but i really think it's
coming to a point where
the media is going to be a real enemy of
people and there has to be one
way for people to get information and
i'm not sure how they're gonna be able
to get it maybe a new news site that's
out there
you know a vt post or something but it's
it's crazy
and this is from just studying it and i
don't want this to happen but you can
just feel it
shifting constantly each month it gets a
little bit worse i mean you know
what what stelzner was saying on cnn uh
last night
he was saying the fact that fox he was
defending fox news
can you imagine a cnn stealther
defending fox was he was defending fox
news
saying the fact that fox uh even though
a lot of republicans right now are not
trusting fox because trump keeps
tweeting stuff out saying you know fox
is not what it used to be etc etc
you know the direction they're going so
when's the last time he saw cnn
defending fox
it's not every day you see that taking
place so maybe some of these media
companies are afraid
and they're distancing themselves a
little bit a little bit from trump like
a fox news
worried that if a new administration
takes place if they're not too neutral
they may experience censorship i don't
know but i think for me
um take a trump administration out and a
biden is in there
what do you talk about on cnn what do
you really tell do you just
every day talk about how biden's the
greatest president of all time what are
you going to talk about
today you will not believe what they did
record break you know phenomenal
you need an enemy but they're not going
to have it without trump and trump was
probably one of the best things that
happened in media
especially for advertising think about
how many eyeballs these guys got
just because it was a guy like trump in
the office so
steve you and i i wanted to wait a
little bit to more the audience got on
so guys if you if you're
if you just jumped on here right now uh
our guest today steve murphy he is the
man who took down pablo escobar if you
want to bring that picture up
with pablo and uh he wrote a book he and
javier pena which we've had on before
the last time he was on the title of the
interview i think we did was who killed
pablo escobar
it was a title got a few million views
three million views to be exact that's
himself right there that's pablo
this event happened when that picture is
what 93 december 2nd 93 december 2nd 93.
from then till today uh i mean you took
down you wrote a book about how you guys
took down pablo escobar
after that from that moment till today
how much have you seen changed
from the the world or different
countries popping out the next pablo
escobar
is there possibilities of having the
next pablo escobar since you guys took
down pablo
absolutely you know and and so on our
speaking tours we open up for q and a
with audiences
you can ask us anything i mean you can
talk about the investigation you asked
about the netflix series narcos we talk
about our personal lives to a certain
degree
but one of the most frequently asked
questions is how
has drug trafficking or the war on drugs
changed since the death of pablo escobar
the world's first narco-terrorist
the world's most wanted criminal of his
day
well but the first answer is can you
still go out on any street corner in the
united states and buy cocaine
we all know the truth you can it hasn't
diminished at all
you look at the prices the supply versus
demand prices are down the wholesale
prices of cocaine in the united states
coming into the united states are down
which is indicative of a large supply of
cocaine coming in
the sad thing is here in the united
states we are the leading consumer
country in the world when it comes to
illegal narcotics
that's a reputation we're not proud of
but it's the truth
so people say well why have a drug war
on drugs you know we're looking at
legalization of marijuana as well as
other drugs out here in the united
states
so this is a lot of people think it's
strange coming from javier now when we
say this
the war on drugs is one of the biggest
misnomers i've ever heard
go back to the time of pablo escobar
we're going after a person who's
responsible for 80 percent
of the cocaine supply in the world wow
now think about this in your occupations
wouldn't you like to have 80
of the markets it's called a monopoly
yes right and that's what he was able to
achieve
so we're going in on this war on drugs
well when you go to the war
you get your allies together you get
your material your personnel
you go in to win what do we do in
colombia
we sent two americans i have your
opinion steve murphy does that sound
like a war
now we had support from the embassy we
had agents just chomping at the bit to
come and join us up there
we had dea offices all around the world
you had law enforcement around the world
wanting to participate and assist
any way they possibly could but it was
not a war
you know it seemed like it because of
all the bombings we're flying in on huey
gunships being shot at as we're coming
in
you're going out on patrols and having
car bombs blow up and kill police
officers that you're traveling with
you've got indiscriminate car bombs
going uh going off around all the cities
bogota medellin and cali
simply because pablo escobar wanted to
impose his will on everybody else
to make him he wanted you know he got
elected as a member of congress
the justice minister rodrigo larbinia
had the stones to stand up and call him
what he was a murderer and a drug
trafficker
we know what happened to him exactly it
cost him his life he played the ultimate
price but you know what the man is a
hero
because he was brave enough to stand up
and tell the truth
well you know maybe if we could do that
here in the united states stand up and
tell the truth yeah
you know not anyway pat can i make one
quick shaman on this photo the first
time i've seen this photo steve
just looking at you the thing that just
jumps out at me
you look relieved like so much of your
life had been spent
obsessing about this guy and maybe you
couldn't even believe it at that time
that he's lying in front of you dead
i mean was it an obsession was that all
that you were consumed with and how long
did it take how long were you after him
well so i wrote
this this picture is the combination of
an 18-month manhunt
but pablo escobar started dealing drugs
in the late 70s early 80s so this was a
long time this is december 1993.
there were two manhunts the first one
before his surrender which he got the
you know the deal of a lifetime where he
surrendered to his custom-built prison
staying there one year and then the day
he country club i mean he built his
prison i mean who gets to build their
own prison it's ridiculous yeah
and you go in there and he had a
two-room suite he had a jacuzzi tub
in his private bathroom you know what we
have the united states
just like everywhere else is group
showers that's right
i mean it's just it's ridiculous but
you're right in the fact that we felt
like the weight of the world had been
lifted off our shoulders my wife
and i had adopted our first daughter we
have two sons that were back in the
united states
it's and i tell people a lot of people
read the book or they see the different
shows and
interviews that we've done and they'll
email us they'll send us messages hey
i'm interested in becoming a de agent
what's it all about
first thing i tell them it's not a job
it's a lifestyle it will affect
every area of your life and you know
what happens
and this is wrong i don't believe in
this i believe i believe our priority
should be god
family job what happens though
your priorities become job family
god okay so that it just becomes
concerning
unfortunately that's not the way it's
supposed to be why is that why do you
say god last
just because you're getting consumed by
things like this every sin in the bible
you have to commit
is that kind of why you're saying god
goes last because to really pull off
what you want to do
you're going to have to do stuff that
you know god wouldn't be is that what
you're saying or no you don't lose your
values in principle no
never okay you never give up yourself
why would god go last though
it's just the way it happens you know
because you're you're consumed by things
like this
i mean i'm living in medium for 18
months my wife's back in bogota and we
adopted our first daughter
so she's back there i can't even spend
time with them javier's family's back in
texas they can't
he can't come and visit his family
because they wanted us both in country
you know every day to handle what was
going on and then when you do get to
come home and see your family
you're kind of focused on them and
that's where they come in second
and then with your principal i grew up a
preacher's kid you know
so god's very strong part of our
family of our beliefs thank god he's a
merciful god and
and forgiving because i had a lot to be
forgiven though
but the thing is we never broke the law
we broke policies and procedures
every day we weren't supposed to go out
on operations we're flying down on
operations every day in helicopter
gunships going on raids you never
broke the law you broke policies and
procedures every day oh they didn't want
us to leave the base the first policy we
broke was leaving the base
bend the rules a little bit right no we
broke it
you know we had we had the us army's
delta force we had the
seal team six from the u.s navy with us
for 18 months and guys i got to tell you
those are the studs of the world
i don't hold a candle to them but
they're military they obey
the rules the orders the policies and
procedures you don't have to
well we're supposed to um but we knew we
couldn't do their job and think about
this
tom think about this what if i said hey
listen i heard pablo escobar's down at
the corner first and maine go see if
he's down there i'm gonna get a cup of
coffee
come back let me find out tell me what
you found out can i take a blackhawk to
go look for him
no but i think how much respect would
you have for me
right how rich was he how i mean
you know we talked about this but how
rich was he
well if you know there's a lot of uh
speculation out there that uh
okay at his in his day and time he was
the richest criminal in the world
go do the research now find out who the
richest criminal has been of all time
he's still number one his his uh
uh estimated wealth is as high as 33
billion i read an article here just
recently where it's
estimated to be at 33 billion dollars
forbes magazine came out seven years in
a row raking
rickingham is the seventh richest man in
the world now i don't know how they came
up their statistics makes you
a little suspicious about that number
right but
you know people say well what about el
chapo not even close not he's i mean
he's a billionaire he's a
multi-billionaire
but not even close to what pablo escobar
was able to amass
and i don't i'm coming across i feel
like i'm coming across excitedly saying
this
this is not a good thing you know none
of his money was earned from legal
pursuits
all of his money was blood money all of
his
money was blood money today who is the
modern day pablo
would it be an el chapo well it's just
it's his successor
a guy who's been around for years who's
a very well-known mexican
ishmael zambada they call him amayo
so when chapa moved up to the united
states to serve the rest of his life in
one of our prisons
uh mayo has taken over his position as
the head of the sinaloa cartel yeah
and ishmael zambot has been around for
years and years he's not a newbie
here's here's the difference though
these guys were pop culture icons
right i mean pablo escobar el chapo you
never heard of this guy
are they being less glamorized now or
are we going to find out more about him
oh you're going to find out more
he's just is he says first of all
you you understand how violent chappa
was i mean we've all read the articles
and seen reports and i've probably seen
things that you haven't had access to
zimbabwe would not have gotten in that
position if he couldn't carry on
you know he's got to mean he's got to
forcefully maintain his
position of leadership which is true in
the dark drug world
you know people say we took out pablo
escobar it had zero effect well that's
because there's so much money involved
and there's so many people in this world
that are waiting to take advantage of
you
and you and me because if it's
if it's drugs okay if it's weapons if
it's counterfeit clothing
whatever the case might be they're
criminals you know and that's what they
know
there's no remorse no guilt feelings in
their actions
so what would the the idea where
oregon's going in the direction of
legalizing all the drugs you know what
what they're thinking about doing is is
that the right direction i'll read
exactly what they're doing organ votes
to decriminalize all drugs
uh uh for uh mental health treatment
first state law of its type makes
maximum fine for possession of any drug
a hundred dollars and increases
treatment which means cocaine
if i have cocaine i'm cut it's a hundred
dollar fine with results from 76 percent
of precincts
reporting early wednesday morning 59
percent of oregonians
approved measure 110 the drug
decriminalis
decriminalization referendum and 56
voted for measure 109
uh according to associated press the
campaign in favor of measure 110 raise
uh 4.5 million dollars the 109 raised
5.7 million dollars
what are your thoughts about what oregon
is doing with drugs is this the right
direction we're going
with legalizing every drug not
legalizing just to find us a hundred
dollars
right so it's it's a it's not
decriminalizing it completely yes it's
reducing
the penalties for it with in the
articles i've read
say that their reasoning is to focus
more on rehabilitation
okay i'm in favor of rehabilitation i
don't think
legalizing or reducing penalties is the
way to go about that
people say well it'll give them more
incentive to get into
rehab why why is it going to give you
more incentive
what we're going to see when you
legalize marijuana
we we recognize marijuana and this might
be my personal opinion or law
enforcement opinion
but i think a lot of americans would
agree with this
it's a gateway drug so i think back to
when i was a kid
you know i'm a little kid in tennessee
somebody stole a beer out of dad's
refrigerator
we all sat around took a drink of beer
because it was cool it was that that
peer pressure thing
tasted like crap you know at that age
but you thought you were cool
and so what's the next step well
somebody stole a bottle of wine out of
dad's refrigerator so we took a drink of
that you know
and that's not so bad so then we're you
know we're graduating into whiskey
into liquor it's the same principle with
narcotics people try marijuana like
that's not so bad
you know it makes you hungry afterwards
i've been told just so you know i've
never smoked marijuana but
i've been told it creates uh what they
call the munchies you know
preacher's boy taking beer away from
that i mean your dad was drinking
my dad oh i i thought you were talking
about your dad i'm like listen that's a
pretty
uh uh aggressive church if pastor comes
i mean those messages got to be powerful
messages
let me tell you my dad was a southern
baptist minister he ruled by the rod
you know he was a legit straight oh
i grew up a very different lifestyle
than most people you know you look at
those numbers in oregon
right 55 went for it i mean are you
kidding me
who believes that who literally thinks
that's a good idea is it just young
people that are saying yes just drug
people that do drugs here's the other
question that's why this thing with city
power so important
if they can manipulate the presidential
election if in fact it did happen yeah
what about some of these propositions
some of these other things in other
states why couldn't they
you know skew the results on that as
well i mean something like
legalizing drugs or what they want to do
in seattle or in washington is legalize
misdemeanors essentially that one came
out yesterday
that just brings more chaos to society
which there is one
faction that wants that so
that the trickle-down effect from the
potential
of this fraud on these voting machines
just goes so deep
well and you look at marijuana and it's
you know people say what's it's harmless
no it's not people say it's a victimless
drug well
a couple of months ago i did a little
spot for a tv station in la where seven
people were murdered in
riverside california marijuana grow site
they didn't take their money they didn't
take their drugs it was a retaliation
attack i mean
to me it looks like it's probably
competition yeah that was the one at
that party right that outdoor party
no no this was a private house and there
were seven people in there that had been
maintaining this grow site
is that victimless when you've got seven
murders that's not victimless
it's ridiculous but now you look at the
we're looking at the hard drugs we're
looking at cocaine heroin
methamphetamine opioids holy cow it's
now
it's now acceptable to have possession
of illegal opioids
you know another thing that's not even
being talked about very much
is the counterfeit medications come to
the united states many of which are
laced with fentanyl
so javier now the last two years we've
been working with a group called
partnership for safe medicines
we've been on capitol hill twice once
for the house side once for the senate
side last year we went spoke to the
american legislative exchange conference
which was legislators from all 50 states
right here well down the road in austin
texas
you know we received a positive
reception from them but i was a little
surprised that
so many of the state legislators were
unaware that this is a problem
people say well we need to be able to
buy our medications from online canadian
pharmacies
talk to the canadian talk to rcmp there
is no such thing as an online canadian
pharmacy
what they do the bad guys will ship it
in from pakistan china india whatever
countries that it may be originating in
it passes through china anybody can
create a website
we've got a website you know it didn't
cost anything very little to create a
website
and you can put you put a picture of a
maple leaf on there and this is what
we're doing
it's all bogus because it passes through
canadians to the canadian law
enforcement
or medical professionals have a
responsibility of checking the package
no it's just a pass-through country so
you don't know what you're getting the
counterfeit
the bad guys what they'll do is they'll
take the active ingredient out of a pill
if it's an opioid they'll take that out
and replace it with with uh with nothing
just leave the binders in there that
hold the pill together
so if you think you're getting cancer
meds you might be taking a placebo and
not know it
they might leave a little bit of the
active ingredient in there but you're
still not getting
what you thought you were right amount
that you thought you were getting right
right and then
if they put fentanyl in there oh my gosh
i mean you guys know it takes three
grains
three or four grains of not grams grains
think of a grain of salt that's enough
for an overdose
it's all prince died exactly so
i mean we're looking at uh what's the
latest numbers i saw
roughly 70 000 deaths from overdose
here in the united states 46 over 46 000
i think were attributed just directly to
opioids
and now in oregon it's okay if you've
got counterfeit opioids or you've got
opioids that you don't have a
prescription for
one of the most dangerous things in our
country and not just
oregon you know d.c passed
have tentatively tentatively passed for
the psycho
psilocybin mushrooms the psychedelic
mushrooms to be legal
in dc now i live outside of these maybe
the politicians need to take some though
maybe they will come out with some new
ideas
bypassing marijuana going right to the
mushrooms aren't you oh i mean party
time
but here's my question for you know i
don't even drink alcohol here's my
here's my question for you though
the way you started it you said uh we're
the number one country in cocaine
it's the cheapest it's ever been
wholesale prices are down which means
it's coming in more
and it's not a statistic we want to lead
in and he said you can go to any street
right now if you wanted to buy cocaine
you could right okay
fine so if you and i today wanted to go
on a project we had the camera crew
following us in a very low-key way to go
on the streets of dallas to see if we
can find cocaine
we're probably going to end up finding
cocaine we may need 30 minutes to an
hour but we're probably
going to end up finding cocaine which
may not be a bad project to put mario
and adam on just to kind of
get arrested be careful just let the
camera roll be careful
be very careful but but here's where i'm
going with it here's where i'm going
with that
the libertarian position many of the
libertarian position is
legalize all of it if you want to put
that on your body do it you know if you
want to kill yourself with it go for it
it's not like you can't kill yourself
with alcohol
many people are killing themselves with
alcohol matter of fact up today there's
only been one person that killed
themselves with marijuana
uh on based on statistics but god knows
how many people have kept
killed himself with alcohol right what's
the big deal if we legalize marijuana
what's the big deal if we legalize these
things it's not like they can't get it
anyways i mean
yourself said you can't get it so if you
can get it if we do legalize it does it
get rid of the drug dealers that are out
there i guess that's the question
well we've legalized marijuana have we
gotten rid of the mexican marijuana
growers have we stopped the violence
not at all it's too lucrative of a
market they make too much money in that
the and what's happened with the
legalized marijuana is the jurisdictions
where it's legal have taxed it so
heavily
it's more expensive so they can buy what
we call skunk weed you know they can buy
the
illegally grown marijuana cheaper so the
market's still there
but here's the other thing should you
and i and tom
should we change our morals and our
standards
for money i don't agree with that when
these people become addicted
are you and you and i who work hard for
our money who pay our taxes
we've worked hard all our lives i'm
retired i'm working as hard now as i
ever did
should we be responsible for creating a
rehabilitation programs would it make a
difference would they have gotten the
drug regardless if it was legal or
illegal
well when it's legal people think well
if it's legal it must be okay it must
not be that bad you think that's what
they think because for me
even though cigarettes are legal and
alcohol is legal
i don't think it's good i mean i every
time i see somebody smoking cigarettes i
tell myself what are you smoking
cigarettes for
i mean we know at this point it's
terrible for what are you smoking how
many more commercials do you need how
many more
you know how many of those things do you
need to see to say this is not something
i want to do i mean it's
families being lost over cigarettes and
alcohol so you know
and if you choose to drink responsibly
let's just say you want to go have a
whiskey let's just say you want to go
have a cigar and a whiskey with friends
okay fine
but uh cigarettes are legal i mean you
remember the movie day
what's that one movie they did with that
one actor that played in uh in um
one of these uh avengers movies or
batman spider-man movie
what's the spider-man movie um anyways
one guy plays a bad guy in
uh he plays a bad a bad guy in batman i
believe
and it's the story of philip morris how
he's going around telling people that
secrets are not bad for you it's okay
for you it's not addicting and he's a
phenomenal lobbyist incredible lobbyist
this movie blew up because
of how he exposed philip morris's
lobbyist how great of a job they were
doing
going out there convincing people it's
not that bad for you then eventually you
have to put the sign saying
if you smoke cigarettes this could kill
you you could get cancer etc etc
so if people are already going to get
their hands on it what's the difference
if it's legal or illegal
the difference is it's going to change
your lifestyle if you become addicted to
it
you can become a non-productive member
of our society no i get that what i'm
asking is but if i can get it
steve being if it's legal i have access
to it
if it's illegal i still have access to
it what is the difference
well i think when you legalize it it
just so you've got people who are saying
and and this has been proven with
marijuana you know i've always wondered
about it well now it's legal let me try
it yeah
becoming addicted to marijuana is is not
going to happen if you smoke a few times
heroin cocaine methamphetamine
opioids the chance for addiction can be
there with the first use
now people are going to argue about it
you're going to get a lot of negative
comments because i said that
go back and read the jurisdictional or
go back and read the researches
the reports that the met a bonafide cdc
or medical research paper not some group
that
yeah i think marijuana should be legal
because i want to try it look at
legitimate
studies and see what's happened
countries around the world have tried
legalizing drugs
with good intent but the truth is if you
go look at them
it hasn't worked in any country yet you
end up with more addicts you got more
people out there that are not working
you've got
you want people sleeping on your front
lawn trying to break in your house so
they can obtain money they say well if
you legalize it then
you know that will cut down on crime you
still got to gain money to buy it just
because it's legal doesn't mean it's
free
you know i i here's a little unofficial
survey i don't see anybody smoking
cigarettes anymore
it almost makes me wonder how big
tobacco stays in business how much
can you pull up how much philip moore's
revenue was in 2020 so far 2019
okay but i can't go a day without
smelling marijuana without seeing people
smoking now it's legal in california
but any you go for a walk it's weight on
the weekends you're smelling it
everywhere you go to lax
and if that's the big new thing now
people smoking pot
outside of lax i smell it all the time
every single week
so holy moly 77
billion us dollars cigarettes
wow think about it they're spending way
less money on advertising so their
profit margins are probably way better
right i mean imagine how much they were
on every magazine you know billboards
they used to
spend so much money clearly they're
getting cigarettes into the hands of
people how much is a pack of cigarettes
how much is a pack of cigarettes today
what's the package would you guys know
or no i mean i have no idea
but type in what's the price of a pack
because anybody knows the price of pack
of cigarettes if you're watching this
comment below obviously you're giving
yourself a way that you kind of know but
i guess i'd guess five bucks right so
let's do the math each pack of
cigarettes how many cigarettes does it
have can you go and do the math
tell me how many cigarettes in a package
20 27 okay 628 let's do the math here
let's do the matthew i'm actually
curious to know
so 628 um divided by 20.
31 cents
figure out how many cigarettes i just
kind of wanted i mean i am such a
he's looking for a new investment 250
billion cigarettes per year
guys 250 billion cigarettes smoked every
year
250 billion man so so 250 billion
cigarette smoke if you took it down to
average of 7.7
what's 250 billion divided by 7.7
billion
if you just did it by 7.7 billion
you're talking about each person on
average smokes 3.2 cigarettes per year
okay each person if each person is
competing for children have you smoked
any this year
i haven't smoked any have you have you
ever
a quarter of a billion cigarettes are
still being smoked per year
oh my god by the way if you're watching
this you're a proud
cigarette smoker and you're willing to
say i smoke
cigarettes proudly i know some of you
guys won't admit to it
but if you're a proud smoker of
cigarettes comment below and say you
smoke cigarettes i'm actually curious
isn't it unbelievable i don't understand
signals that's the one thing i don't
understand
i understand weed i don't wanna sound
cigarettes right and to think that
people used to smoke on airplanes
30 40 years ago yeah i mean it was
everywhere now it's just not cool
anymore well you see the old movies even
in congress
you're testifying before congress and
they're sitting there smoking the
cigarette they're in an open conference
well you know
uh biden wants to legalize marijuana
across the board
nationwide similar to the federal
minimum wage that they want to do across
the board they want to legalize
marijuana so
if you're watching this if you're
watching this you saw the little banter
that we have here
press thumbs up if you say legalize
marijuana
push thumbs down is if you say
absolutely not do not legalize marijuana
right now we have 334 thumbs up two
thumbs down so we'll see what's going to
happen with the difference there
with thumbs up and thumbs up i'm
actually curious what the you know
average viewer thinks
whether we should legalize it or not let
me say one more thing about marijuana
now
um and again this is uh kind of odd
coming from you know i was a cop for 38
years javier was also
if i don't believe that anybody
should live in chronic pain if you have
cancer whatever
the medical condition is it causes you
chronic pain legitimate
not not self-imposed but uh or
created in your own mind yeah imaginary
and if if smoking
weed relieves you of that pain if
psychologically you think that relieves
you the pain
quite honestly i don't have a problem
with it but that's medical marijuana
that's not
you know growing your own weed in the
backyard or going out buying skunk weed
from somebody out in the field
i just don't think that anybody deserves
to live in that kind of pain and
we've had family members pass from from
cancer as well as
other illnesses so i know that's kind of
odd coming from us
or when i say us i'm talking about
javier as well because we've had long
discussions about this
but legalizing these other drugs
including marijuana
i don't think is the answer what is the
answer well i think
i think we should do a much better job
at educating our
young people at the earliest possible
age so i've got
five granddaughters now if i have to
scare the crap out of them at the
youngest age possible
to get them to realize how bad the
effects of narcotics are
i'm okay with that and i love my
granddaughters i'll do anything for them
but we need we need to do a better job
of educating we used to have the dare
program a past
yeah say no to drugs a past organization
did away with the budget was that nancy
reagan is that the
yeah yeah yeah the education part is so
important it starts at home if you can't
train your kids by yourselves you're
screwed because and then what about all
these families
where the parents smoke marijuana
they're smoking pot so they're
experiencing it
throughout their childhood they're
seeing it it's accepted their friends
are doing it
me personally i just here's one message
i preach
you're a loser if you do drugs and i
just stay with that with all three of my
kids and it's working so far
well you know dea has a program i'm not
speaking as dea because i'm retired
and i'm not an expert on this you know
at all but i'm aware of an initiative
they have called the 360 strategy
so people want to come in and say hey
law enforcement is your responsibility
stop drugs
one organization can't stop it it's so
prevalent in our society
so what they've done is 360 goes into a
city a high-risk city
and they bring every component of the
city together so you've got your law
enforcement
your court system your politicians your
doctors your pharmacies your housewives
the faith-based community everybody
comes in and collectively works
to come up with a solution to whatever
the drug problem is in their community
and they're seeing some successes is it
overwhelming success no but they are
seeing progress
so i think that's a pretty uh pretty
good operation i think whoever thought
that up in dea did a phenomenal job
coming up with the concept
but also i'm a big proponent of
self-acceptance and responsibility for
your actions
our society today has become so
permissive anything's okay
i mean it's just ridiculous what's going
on out there right
so but you know i knew if i did certain
things
i was going to pay the price with my dad
and i you know i knew what my
i did grow up in a rough upbringing
because of what was expected
but that was the bottom line i knew what
was expected and i knew what the penalty
was if i didn't live up to expectations
so why don't we have that now why is it
okay for you to go do everything you
want to do
when you're hurting other people you
know it's just
i'd like to see us get back to where
we're making good sound decisions and we
accept our responsibilities for a bad
decision
yeah i i i tell my kids the story my two
sons i sat him and i said you know who
the president is yes president trump
i said do you know his uh older brother
no who is he fred trump do you know what
happened to him no he died do you know
how he died no from drinking too much
alcohol
he drank too much alcohol became an
alcoholic and then he eventually killed
himself you know who doesn't drink any
alcohol who president trump
why not it's a personal decision that he
made so the i go through that process
so then uh i told the story i think a
couple months ago
uh uh so we had some people over and we
have alcohol in the closet so she opens
it up in our nan he says yeah that's
alcohol
and my son comes up to me my
seven-year-old he says daddy why do we
have alcohol in dallas if you say
alcohol kills people why do we have a
lookout they hold you accountable right
right and my oldest son trying to
protect me says
dylan daddy has alcohol in the house in
case something happens you get a wound
to put alcohol on it that's why we're
good for him
it's interesting you know how he thinks
about it but you know by the way quick
shout out to a couple people here good
mother
just gave a hundred dollars the world is
laughing because we have women
ruining our country the polarization is
between the sexes
the mr mr mystery needs to stop
then we had another one that came back
from good mother the strong
women need to stand up and put our crazy
sisters in their place
i've given men permission to speak the
truth i don't know what just happened i
mean i think adam just created a
movement of women on this because he
said there's only one here
but uh you know shout out to those uh to
to the good
uh mother that gave that um
donation right there the hundred dollars
and the ten dollars but uh
are our men being kind of uh uh you know
pansified a little bit like are they
being you know sold as
you know men are weak is that kind of a
campaign that you're seeing because
i have a couple guys that i work with i
have a friend of mine had a conversation
with them over the weekend probably
a good 90-minute conversation when my
son was doing basketball practice on
sunday
i had this conversation with this friend
of mine and i recommended him a few
years ago
a book and the reason why i recommended
him this i mean i don't know how we got
to this topic but i think it's a
conversation we need to have i'm kirsten
or what a man's man's going to say about
this
so you know i noticed every time we go
out
he was so uncomfortable and on the edge
around his wife
it was like this guy couldn't enjoy
himself oh my gosh
oh my gosh oh my gosh all this other
stuff right now one day i'm
sitting there talking to him so let me
ask you a question who do you spend more
time with mom or dad mom are you mama's
boy and
my mom is okay cool you know it's great
mama's boys it's phenomenal
i had a great laugh with my mom the
other day uh where somebody from armenia
called
my ban my mom from the middle east baku
or zabaraja called my mom and said do
you know who your son is
do you know what your son said about the
armenian community give us your son's
number we want to call him and
congratulate him
my mom's like you want me to give you my
son's number he says he says
my son barely has time to talk to him
his own family you think he's going to
call
you just we had a good laugh together
but uh
so you know we're sitting on listen tell
me about your relationship why are you
the way you are you're so
on uh walking on excellence all the time
so i said read this book
which by the way i highly recommend this
book for any man
it's called no more mr nice guy okay and
his book
explains how men used to be raised being
around their fathers more working on the
farm
so kind of like somebody like your dad
that would push him around toughen them
up all that other stuff
and after generation boys were raised
spending more time around moms than they
were around their
fathers and they got a little bit softer
to where now
men are not as strong as manly as they
once used to be now this is what the
author talks about
phenomenal book no more mr nice guy i
recommend
every nice guy to read no more mr nice
guy for many different reasons
do you think there's any credence to men
being a little bit soft nowadays
jeez don't get them started here oh my
gosh
be gentle because we don't want to
offend our nice guys please
no you know people tell me i'm a nice
guy
you know honestly i grew up a mama's boy
because
it was easier to get things from my mom
and it was my dad right
i've always considered myself a mama's
boy but i don't think that makes you
weaker
you know and i don't see anything wrong
with being a mama's boy that's i'm a
huge on on the quality of the sexes if
you're doing the same amount of work you
deserve the same amount of pay you
deserve the same amount of recommend
recognition um
did you ever get an answer from the guy
why he was yeah did he nervous around
his wife oh he wrote the book oh yeah
he read the book and and and things
changed in their relationship
and uh uh but you know again i see a lot
of people that try to appease and
conform
way too much uh and they try to please
everybody in their lives all the time
and sometimes when you do that you're
not able to enjoy your
the things that you want to do in your
life because you're always worried about
what about what this
what about that person things now
there's a different story between
wanting to make your parents proud i
want to make my mom and dad proud
there's nothing wrong with that i want
to make sure my mom
you know looks up and says that's my son
i'm proud to have a son there's nothing
wrong with that
but the part about like for example in
the middle eastern community by the way
the author's name is robert glover i'm
telling you
i highly recommend this book i've never
met the author
i've read the book multiple times he
owes you a thank you today
and just so everybody knows this is a
robert can you put the can you put the
picture up here just so we can give this
guy a shout out
and and you know what if anybody knows
robert glover and if robert glover
anybody sends this podcast to you
send them send us a message maybe we'll
bring you on here to say
to get you to talk some smackdown how
did you read it for the first time did
you think you were being too nice
no not at all so i so i had i was
reading a book called the way of man by
an author that's a very weird author
remember this guy
he came over here we interviewed him
he's a gay republican okay and he was
he's not anymore he was at the time and
he kind of changed and the interview was
a little bit awkward so you know at the
end of the interview he says well you
know i kind of wish this interview can
we cut this can we cut that kind of like
listen we don't do cuts we just give the
interview and i said let's just sit on
the interview we never went live with
the interview right
but when i read the book the way of man
it recommended
no moments for nice guys so i just said
let me go buy all these books because
i'm leading an organization with a lot
of agents
some of them were going through this we
started recommending this book
and and it changed for some people but
going back to uh going back to the
question of
uh normal mr nice guy i don't know i
just see a lot of people nowadays that
are
constantly trying to please everybody
all the time everybody all the time
and there's an element of when you're
trying to please everybody all the time
you cannot spread your wings you know at
some point you're gonna my mom
and dad would fight and my dad i'll
never forget what my dad would say to my
mom
my mom my dad would say why are you so
why are you like this with this
these kids you realize they're gonna do
the same thing we did and she says what
do you mean
i said your kids are gonna grow up one
day just like you left your mom and dad
to go build your own family one day
they're gonna leave you
and go build their own family they gotta
be independent right so my dad was a
little bit trying to build independence
she was more trying to
build you know attachment and stick
around and all that other stuff it's
very common in middle eastern community
middle eastern marriages let me give you
an idea how middle eastern marriages
work maybe a little bit closer to latino
and you guys can can completely say it's
also similar
an american type of marriage but let me
give you middle eastern marriage so say
a boy a man
decides to get married and they're
armenian
okay but the guy's armenian the girl's
mom and dad both sides very much
involved
there's a lot of politics one side will
say he shouldn't be doing this the other
side will say she shouldn't be doing
this
it's so much you should raise your kids
this way you guys shouldn't do that all
this [ __ ]
should should constantly which you
should be doing and
what it typically ends up doing is the
the two that got married they loved each
other they're crazy about each other i
mean if you said
yes i do you love this woman or this man
at one point right
what caused this division between a
husband and wife these are good friends
of mine what caused the division between
the husband and wife
family is getting involved almost nine
out of ten times his family's poking the
girl
and poking the guy and say you yeah what
you're doing you should do this
and sometimes the man's like oh my gosh
yes mom you're right yes mom so mom
becomes a priority over
the wife you know when i got married
i told my mom a very interesting thing i
don't know if i told you the story the
day i got married
so i'm getting married i sent my mom
then i said for the last 30 years
you've been the number one woman of my
life effective june 26th you're gonna be
number two
so you had an official meeting with your
mom telling her the rain is over you
know what i said
here's what i said you cannot say
anything about our family and how we
want to raise our kids
unless if you want to pay for it and if
you want to raise them if you're not
going to pay for it you're not going to
raise them
we're going to raise our kids the way we
want to raise them and you may disagree
with that it's totally fine
but that's how we're going to raise our
kids she sat there at first it wasn't
because this is not an armenian thing to
do
for a son to say something like this but
we live in america
and we moved on and it's great you know
family is good it's probably important
you set the tone right yeah so to me
some when i say no more mr nice guy i
listen kai is a mama's boy i freaking
love it but kai is also a man's man
because his dad's a tough guy
okay he's a he he he talks he's such a
family guy
he'll sit there in his cubicle he's
speaking in his norwegian language which
i think half the time they're talking
[ __ ] about us but you know
and then they'll start talking and all
this stuff and he'll just come in the
middle of a meeting he says hey my mom
wants to say hi
and his mom's very talkative if you're
watching i love talking to you but you
you can talk
and so all of a sudden she'll go 45
minutes or an hour talking but you know
what
as much as kai is close to his family
he's going to go to spend time with his
family for a couple of weeks
the guy is still a man's man he still
has that independence so
i think that mixture of having both is
so necessary
sometimes when you get too much of it on
one side with men they become too nice
and you know they don't spread their
wings what are your thoughts tom about
this you know what i want to read that
book
shonda don't get upset if he reads this
oh my god
shonda's gonna say screw that book oh
she'll burn it i mean
i might get a little liberation i mean
it'll be like a coup in the house i have
a say
in something you know what you talk
about a five foot two dictator man i
mean she
but it's all good um how do you get that
book
amazon you you will i'm being sincere
with everybody
yeah i highly recommend that book i
don't make a penny off this guy i've
never met the author i have no idea who
he is
but it's a phenomenal book for anybody
to read so do you have any other
opinions on that with the
men that are sometimes too soft or no no
not really yeah
you know everybody's all right set your
own standards you are a nice guy live up
to your studio you know what steve
you're a nice guy i don't care what
pablo said about you i think you're a
nice guy
uh you know we'll we'll stay there so
what story do we want to get into
we got a lot of different stories to get
into uh do we want to get into the
ammunition so why don't we talk about
that since we have steve here vista
outdoors reports ammunition backlog over
a billion dollars we currently have a
we currently have over a year's worth of
orders for ammunition in excess of one
billion met said during a november fifth
call
with demand for outstripping supply and
inventory levels in the channel at our
all-time lows
at all-time lows we see strong demand
continuing and this metric
informs our viewpoint of what a recovery
normalization
could look like vista was reporting its
second quarter earnings when ceo chris
meltz
detailed what announced the backlog
which he called
unprecedented for the for the company an
estimated 1.9 million firearms were sold
october this year 1.9 million firearms
that's a 65
spike from the same month in 2019
according to data provided by small arm
analytics
and forecasting so you know is this a
good thing is this a bad thing and what
is it telling us about the current state
of things i think it's a spotlight on
what's going on in this country you
can't have a conversation with someone
right now
where they haven't said oh i'm gonna get
a gun or i just got a gun oh i got my
gun ready do you know how often people
say that
doctors doctor friends of mine are
constantly telling me about the guns
they have
when i see this too i'm going are
americans that bad of shots that we need
that much
ammunition oh my god can't we hit
anything very good
a huge backlog of ammunition here's the
other thing can't they make more
i mean you would think this is a golden
opportunity for them to just really
capitalize on this because it's not
going away
um the political climate is completely
driving this it's not like we're under
quarantine and people have more time to
go
hunting right it's because people are
fearful
hell i've never owned a gun pat you know
i've never owned one but
i want to get one i mean you've never
owned it i've never owned a gun and
you're a conservative yes but i've i'm
i you know i grew up with hunters
everybody in my family hunts
i've never cast a fishing pole hell i
could do more damage with a tool i could
probably hurt somebody just trying to
fix something
you know change a light bulb and i could
kill three people
so you've never shot a gun okay one time
when i was living in omaha i had a
friend who was a police officer in omaha
we went to the shooting range and she
let me do it but
i've never had the interest to i've
never felt threatened i've never felt
like i needed a gun
but i'm i'm definitely going to get one
now are you
how do you talk to your kids about guns
how do you talk to you you know what i'm
a little bit worried about i don't like
the thought of having a
because i'm not a gunman you know i i
don't like the thought of a novice
like me having a gun in the house i
would want to make sure i was doing
all the right things have one of those
uh fingerprint safes where that's the
only way you can get it
that's the way i would do it but you
know what it's not a topic because it's
not something
that i'm into i don't take them hunting
i don't do that kind of stuff we don't
watch
you know violent shows like that so it
really is the only shooting i'm talking
about is teaching dash
you know flawless jump shots and you
know how to get off a screen and that
kind of thing but
i this is this is a very eye-opening
stat here the fact that we have this
much ammunition that people want to buy
that they can't
steve what do you think well i'm i'm a
country boy so
i grew up hunting you know
since the early stage i can remember
have a rather large variety of weapons
now in my house
and it's it's quite honestly i do have a
weapon or two for personal protection in
the house but the rest of it i'm just a
collector
you know i have a couple collectors
items that i'm really proud of i've got
a 20th anniversary dea
45 colt 45 1911 that's
never even had the slide pulled back on
it it's in pristine it's still got the
core diet on it and everything
um but i agree exactly with with what he
just said
in the fact that this is being
politically motivated
you know i mean i've got a i guess
now that i stopped thinking about i do
have a pretty large array of ammunition
in my house
just because i used to shoot competition
but you know what i retired from dea
in 2013 so over seven years ago i've
carried a gun twice
since then believe it or not from 2013
until today only twice
yeah believe it or not so you feel
pretty safe in america today well
where i live is pretty safe it's you
know it's uh
it's today one of them
[Laughter]
i can't carry it on the plane anymore so
what do you say if you're having a
conversation with a
man that's getting married who has kids
what is your advice
about having gun in the house well i
think
okay so being a country boy i think we
have responsibilities as a
as the father as the male leader of the
house that doesn't make you the leader
of your wife
but you're the male leader of your house
i think one of our responsibilities is
to teach our children about weapons
now my two sons i taught them how to
hunt uh you know the first thing you
teach them is gun safety i used to be a
firearms instructor for dea first thing
you teach is gun safety second thing you
teach them is how to clean that stupid
gun because that's the thing you hate to
do
that will keep you from shooting so much
because you've got to clean your weapons
or they won't function correctly
but the safety is the biggest thing now
i say that i'm responsible for teaching
my children i've never taken either one
of my daughters out to shoot
but my oldest daughter who she's 27 now
i've seen pictures of her on a range
shooting an ar-15
she's 4 foot 11. the gun is taller than
she is
she's right out there so i'm an advocate
of teaching gun safety
because you never know what you're going
to encounter you know when we were going
overseas one of the things the
additional trainings that dea put you
through
is they would send you to quantico for a
couple weeks and one of the big classes
was weapon familiarization
because you never know what you're going
to encounter i've never seen an ak-47
until i got to columbia
thankfully i knew how it operated
because it i
need a rose you know so you need i think
you need that training if nothing else
to develop that respect for the firearm
this this junk that's going on about
outlawing firearms
well okay let's take all the guns away
from the legal people from all of us
none of us can have guns anymore you
think the criminals are going to abide
by that
what a stupid thought to have that's one
of the most ridiculous as stupid as that
is why are millions buying it
i have no idea i i just
i think they will as i say i guess i'd
refer this as the herd mentality because
this is what
the people that i associate with myself
with that's what they think so that's
what i'm going to think
i don't want to have an independent
thought i don't want to go out and
experience it for myself and find out
what the truth is
i'm just going to go with other people
what they tell me to do which
that's kind of like what the media would
like to do i think well you know they're
coming after the
guns i mean we don't want to turn this
conversation into it but you would
imagine that is on the checklist of of
uh
agenda items of what they want to
accomplish well i mean
in this room just so you know there's
m16s in this rooms and there's guns in
this room
in this room okay uh in a safe back
there there's plenty of ammunition here
in this room
in the house there's plenty as well i'm
all about it
i think men should have it uh you know
the moment you get to a point when you
have a kid
the thing you ought to consider having
by the way i fully also understand folks
who are raised in an environment that
maybe they didn't have you were raised
around hunters and you know
you know minnesota right it's a very
normal thing to have but i do think it's
something that you ought to have and
nowadays
you know steve sometimes the most basic
thing like i asked my nanny why didn't
nanny why didn't i like guns she says
because i don't want the kids to have
access to it i said well then you can
buy
safes that kids don't because sometimes
you know country folks sometimes have
guns sitting on their shelf and all of
it like it's comfortable stuff like
yeah we got one right here i got a
shotgun you know if somebody comes in i
can just pull it out
but i think sometimes it's safety and
nowadays you can literally get one of
these saves it's right next to my bed
you put your finger bone
two seconds gun is out you're good to go
rather than let me go
let me pick it up let me open up the
safe no boom boom
boom and then you're the only one that
can get in there yes you know you can
control it to make
uh uh the fingerprint be you your wife
and whoever else you want and then
nobody else okay you can do it one two
three people
they have that kind of system few
hundred dollars to get one it's not like
you're spending that kind of money
so okay i mean you you can kind of by
the way for those of you that are
watching this
how many guys do own a gun if you own a
gun just put a thumbs up if you say you
know what i own a gun
put a thumbs up how many of you never
never you will never own a gun in your
mind i will never buy a gun
put thumbs down by the way the votes we
did for legalizing marijuana it was 280
to 35.
yes i guess i'm a minority huh you know
but no it's the way the country is i
mean we're we're uh desensitized to it i
mean most states have it i mean we
almost assume now
that you're kind of a backward state if
it's not legal does that mean 80 percent
of valuetainers smoke wheat i mean i
don't know what that means is that well
it's an 80
of podcasters maybe that followed this
podcast pablo had 80
of the cocaine market it's just falling
right in line
so so i think what steve is saying is
we're in the wrong business we may want
to consider it a new business you know i
think steve's considering a new business
selling some of that ammo you have in
your house i saw a light bulb go off
when you realize
how much you have sitting around in the
house there's a market for it you know
honestly i didn't know that was a
problem until i was um
i go to a gym most morning monday
through friday
very early and and some of the guys in
there are rather conservative and
they're big muscle-bound guys
and uh i heard them talking one day
about not being able to get ammo and
they ordered it and there's a
three-month backlog and
that's crazy i couldn't believe it i was
shocked to learn that that was just here
probably in the last month or so i mean
what's the point of having a gun if you
can't get ammo
i mean that's a major problem well so we
went
uh some of the articles that javier and
i used back in the
fight against pablo escobar are now on
display at the mob museum in las vegas
and one of the things they have is my
smith and wesson nine millimeter that i
carried
you know back during that time is just
on display in the case and some other
items
and when i went to ship it out there i
had to go to a gun shop where they had a
federal firearms license so they could
ship it for them illegally
and i was shocked at how few weapons
were in the case i'm used to going into
gun stores and there's
lines and lines of rifles and shotguns
and just cases full of handguns
i was shocked at how small the inventory
was in this gun shop
the fact that more americans want to buy
guns right now in october was record
breaking 65
just tells you where we are today and
how people are feeling because a lot of
these people that are buying guns are
probably not traditional gun owners that
they have a collection these are a lot
of people that are saying look i just
want to get a gun to make sure my
family's safe i have no idea how to use
this
but i'm going to go get a gun to see uh
uh to make sure
my family's protected and that leads me
to the one state that definitely needs
more gun owners california okay
so newsom is saying he is considering
a state-wide curfew daily cover 19 cases
have doubled in california over the last
10 days forcing the governor's office to
pull an emergency break newsom said
at a press conference detailing the
state's response a total of 41 out of
california's 58 counties
are now classified as purple the tier of
kovit-19 related spread
requiring the strictest lockdown
guidelines just 13 counties were
classified purple last week
newsom said his team is reviewing
studies from france germany and saudi
arabia
on the efficacy of their strategies as
it relates to curfews the governor
referred statewide curfews of interest
in massachusetts and virginia as
examples of what california's
could resemble california officials are
still in discussions on whether to
implement the curfew
and key details about how it could be
enforced since you are from california
how excited are you about this i can't
wait
bring it on i mean every day when that
guy speaks i just feel energized and
motivated and i want to buy a gun
that's usually the end and end result of
listening to him
it's coming it's each day they're
thinking of new ways and i'm just
wondering what's the end game what are
they trying to accomplish
by stripping away this you said you go
to the gym every day we haven't had gyms
open since
april march i mean they've been closed
all summer you just get used to it now
the fact that you can't go
into a restaurant bars aren't open gyms
aren't open
basketball nets aren't up because you
don't want people playing basketball
right now
you could dive coven you know it's a
proven fact you play a game on
one-on-one you're dying
it's over um newsome you know and he's
such
he is such a hypocrite it's just
unbelievable and he's even pissing
people off that like him
you know the fact that he had that
dinner in napa valley for 12 people
a 50th birthday party that he's had to
apologize the sacramento bee
ripped him you know really they gave him
a
a really harsh editorial um it's coming
and and garcetti's talking about even
more restrictions for la county
it's next week ask me because there will
be so many more limitations orange
county
who looks at themselves as kind of you
know a maverick almost they like to do
their own thing
they just got hammered yesterday they
have to shut everything down
churches you name it i mean it's just
it's so bad
and they do it in a way that it almost
is normalizing
how you think of things you get used to
it like we have two kids
that are very active in sports you're
used to hauling them around constantly
right pat you're always taking your kids
to practice
to a game you gotta coordinate your
schedules it's been seven months without
doing it and
it would feel weird doing it again so i
think
this is all part of a scheme to just
slowly they're using covent i'm not
saying it's not a disease and people
aren't dying of it
and people aren't suffering from it but
it is a politicized weapon
and california is at the forefront of
how they're using it
steve i agree with you 100 percent
although i am a mask wearer i'm
social distancing this is other than
flying on an airplane a couple of times
since this all started this is as close
as i've been to most people
my wife and i because of our
semi-retirement status now if we go out
to eat
it's usually mid-afternoon when there's
nobody else in the restaurants
and as i mentioned before we started the
podcast today
when this all first started i thought it
was a politically motivated
uh approach by the democratic party to
be quite honest with you
until my son my oldest son is an
orthopedic surgeon in atlanta
and i would talk to him about it and he
sent me a letter
that a colleague of his had written a
guy he went to med school with out of
tulsa oklahoma they
graduated western university med school
and i read this guy's on the front lines
now my son is a is a pediatric
orthopedic surgeon he specializes in
pediatric spinal surgery so he's not
directly on the front line when he's not
doing surgeries he's supporting those
that are on the front lines
when i read what his colleague his buddy
was going through on a daily basis and
the the just
watching people die and not being able
to do anything about it
changed my opinion completely so
i believe that this is an issue
is it as big as the media has blown it
up to be that i'm not sure
but it does not hurt me to wear a mask
people say i have a right not to wear a
mask
i don't remember reading that in the
constitution you know
a mask is not about doing what this
party or that party or the government
tells you to do i'm wearing a mask is
respect
that i'm going to respect your space i
would appreciate if you wear a mask
you know they've done studies you see
the the
nih and cdc come out with studies when
you look at the percentages if both of
us are wearing a mask the
possibility if this is true the
possibility of us
passing the the virus to each other is
drastically drastically reduced
so out of respect for everybody else in
the world i'm going to wear a mask you
don't want a mirror mask i don't care
that's your decision you know i think
you can use the data however you want i
think people on the other side can say
that there is no benefits
cdc and i'm not arguing with you or
telling you you're wrong
but you know you have to wear one in
california you when you're out you have
to wear one so
you you have to do it but man i don't
think
you know being indoors i don't know if
you need a mask uh
if you have some symptoms or if you've
tested positive or
i don't know i i don't i think it's odd
when people wear
young healthy people wear masks inside
what's really odd is you see somebody in
the car by themselves wearing a mask are
people jogging and they're wearing them
i can't be healthy breathing in those
fibers yeah i posted something on
twitter
uh uh five months ago i don't know if
you remember that guy
and it created a rocket six months ago i
saw a guy literally wearing a mask i
took a picture of it
and i said wearing a mask in a car
driving by yourself
is like wearing a condom in bed while
you're by yourself
what do you have a condom there's nobody
around you then you have a condom on and
you're going to
maybe some people do that i don't know
you know you go through the news
the one word you see more than anything
is safe
everything has got to be safe are we
safe this
could you imagine when lewis and clark
were trying to
you know move their way west and
settlers and
it's just constantly having the word
safe in front of you is anti-american
i i think they are desensitizing
americans with the only thing that
matters is we have to save every life
you know we have to make sure
everybody's safe 100 of the time there's
no way you should be in jeopardy of
contracting this virus so we're going to
do
everything we have to to make sure that
you're safe it's wearing me out
they're going to legislate our safety so
that's what's uh
and the media on the front line but
here's the thing i mean if you don't
mind sharing you
you said when you go back home tonight
when you fly back what did you say
you're going to do when you go back i'll
self isolate for 10 days
self isolate in the basement for 10 days
so steve's not just saying this and you
would probably consider yourself a
conservative
very very construed and he's still pro
mask and he's going to suffer i say
self-isolate for 10 days do you stay
away from your wife because she wasn't
on this trip then
or your grandkids yes yes just you for
10 days well
like at dinner if so we don't go out and
eat when i'm on in
self-isolation and this is only this
will be the third time it's happened
since this whole thing started so i
don't travel too much now
but uh if we order in then i'll sit in
the dining room and my wife will sit in
the kitchen so we can talk to each other
you know it's it's just we're in the
high risk group because of our ages
you know depending on who you listen to
and it's just not worth the risk i fully
agree with you on that part about high
uh high risk group ages one yesterday i
spoke to dr stephen gundry
who uh uh uh very he has done ten
thousand
heart surgeries in his life okay he's a
legend when it comes down to that world
and i talked about math because he made
a video about masks
and he made one video saying masks don't
work he says there's no way in the world
this he says as a doctor i wear a mask
for other reasons but for you
you can wear a mask and i still can get
coronavirus through you
and then you know i started asking
questions of what what's your position
nice is now i believe people should be
wearing masks said your position changed
he says yes it did if i was wrong i said
it i'm wrong so
he is now about wearing masks but what
found she said yesterday i don't know if
you guys caught what she said
yesterday found she said yesterday kai
did you hear what five she said
yesterday
found she said we may need to wear a
mask forever
in america moving forward meaning this
masked thing
may be a permanent thing in america
think about that forever
we will be wearing masks i think it's an
incredibly harmful thing for him to say
the way the data changes what we just
yesterday the news
was about a new vaccine that has a 95
effectiveness rate so what are you
talking about
more fear more scaring people how the
hell do you know that you don't even
know what's going to happen
in two weeks regarding coronavirus you i
mean and then they're telling trying to
tell you i mean the cdc
literally has rules out you can find it
about what you should be doing
over the holidays and not singing and
doing all this outside of what the
states are telling you in your your
local governor
the cdc is as well but man that that was
a dangerous statement for him to say
and why bum people out to that level why
can't we have hope
that the vaccine is going to work that'd
be like a mis
uh like an uninformed opinion about
mumps you know mumps are going to be
here forever
measles are going to be deadly for the
rest of time
you know and not giving our medical
communities a chance to get rough when
they're flirting with people though i
mean just think about it for the
flirting community
so everybody's like hey you should let's
just say someone's got pretty eyes and
like how you doing and then all of a
sudden the mask comes down you're like
dude
i totally screwed up what do we do now
you go on a date you know do you make
out with a mask on like
it's like so first base used to be what
first base is first base holding what's
first space kissing it's first place
if first base is kissing but that's
without a mask so what is it halfway
it's like with a mask if we get
i'm halfway there to first base is
kissing but this thing's getting very
technical for me i mean if i was single
today be very complicated
thank god i'm married because i don't
have to worry about that stuff but the
single world
man you go on a date hi so what's your
name
you know can i see what you look like
then the grill is all jacked up and
i don't know i i just i'm very concerned
for the single community you know what
there's a big tinder's taking a big kid
by the way just so you know that tinder
is taking a massive hit today
for our tinder community out there clear
mass that's probably the way so you can
actually see what somebody looks like
those freak me out though have you seen
the clear mask
have you seen the clear mask what do you
think about it when you see a clear mask
actually what do you think about i'm
curious what do you guys think about it
when you see
people with a clear mind you've never
seen it you have seen it
i've seen it you're going there they're
wearing these masks goes like up to here
oh and it's glass masks yeah what do you
think about that
oh no i saw on the dallas dfw last night
when i landed
to me it's like a little bit uh uh it's
like neiman marcus ish you know because
you know when you wear one of those
ghetto masks i feel like you go to
walmart
when you wear one with like some cloth
or maybe you're going to macy's but when
i see this glass type of step like
a shield you're like listen maybe it's
you know apple mask
apple should come out by the way apple
could probably monetize this they come
out with a mask and there's a screen
you're watching tv
and you have the mask on it's next they
would probably do something like that
yeah
well they have masks now that you wear
around your ears but this part is clear
i saw one at dfw last night when i
landed here yeah that's the ones i was
talking about they're freaky i don't
like it
it was it was i don't know why but it
was
it is what it is i just again it's a
very very weird time when it comes onto
these masks and fouchy
said by the way if you're watching this
i know many of you guys are die-hard
fouchy fans
fauci said wear a mask forever
how many of you are very comfortable
knowing you're gonna have to wear a mask
for the rest of your life can i say can
i vote now
you are you're really not no not i don't
want to wear a mask the rest of my life
that's what found you saying though you
know i think vouch is a clown
i really do i think he's lost all
credibility every other week he says
something stupid
he backpedals he's a whiner you know he
can't take it when trump says something
about him i would like
the head epidemiologist or whatever his
title is for 35 years
to be a little stronger can we recommend
fauci read that book
no more mr nice guy i mean he really
needs it the guy's a wuss
he really is no more mr nice guy
that's classic that's classic why don't
we talk about
education when we talk about education a
warren urges biden to bypass congress
and cancel student debt kai do you want
to pull up that article
if you already have it so biden's saying
10 000
is what i wanted to pay maybe we'll go
up to forgiven 50 000
but elizabeth warren is saying let's
just cancel
all of student debt meaning all 1.5
trillion dollars of it
forgive all of it is what she is saying
president-elect
biden is already committed we interim
private is going to come okay so we know
that part
uh cancelled billions of dollars of
student loan debt
he can cancel billions of dollars of
student loan debt giving tens of
millions of americans an immediate
financial boost and helping to close the
racial wealth gap
this is the single most effective
executive
action available for massive economic
stimulus biden harris can lower the drug
okay so
go on that part do you have the stats
because this is what ben shapiro said go
to ben shapiro which i totally agree
with them
how about this instead of forgiving
everybody's college debt
we force all of them kai can you move
please
we force all the colleges who scam
millions of americans into degrees
in useless theory masquerading as
valuable life skills to grant
refunds that would end the grift right
quick i agree with them did you get that
data i asked you for last night can you
pull up that data so okay here's what it
looks like
1987 1988 a four-year college degree
costs you nine thousand dollars okay
this is 2017 okay so a non-profit a
a a public a private was 22 000.
and then it went all the way up to today
the nine thousand dollars today is
twenty one thousand dollars the nine
thousand
the 22 000 is 46 000 and that's just
college tuition and that's
that that number is very small by the
way kai uh
this is per year not uh four years per
year is what we're looking at
from twenty two thousand to forty six
colleges went from being a place you
went to to get a degree to now being a
business model third these numbers are
averages while the 2017 2018 median
private nonprofit prices was 35 thousand
dollars 10 of full-time students
attended institutions with prices below
dollars and thirteen percent attend
institutions charging fifty one thousand
dollars or more
thirteen percent are paying more than
two hundred thousand dollars for their
four-year
of college in terms of percentage the
price of public education has jumped 130
percent
the price of private education has
jumped up 111
kai can you can we look at one thing can
we look at one thing
um what does it look like uh the other
data i asked yesterday was what
the endowment of universities do you
have that the endowment of universities
this is top 10 endowment make it a
little bigger
harvard's sitting on 41 billion dollars
41 billion dollars worth they're sitting
on right now endowment cash
yale is sitting on 30 billion stanford's
sitting on 28 billion give or take
princeton 25 26 billion mit sitting on
17 billion
university of pennsylvania sitting on
14.6 say 15 billion texas a m's got 13
billion
michigan's got 12.2 billion notre dame's
got 11 and a half billion
columbia university's got 11 billion
dollars
they're worried about making college
more available to the average american
why not go pressure universities to
lower prices when they're sitting on so
much cash themselves
what do you think about what elizabeth
warren's saying you know what
the first question i have when i hear
elizabeth warren saying that
from my perspective is how can anybody
take her serious or how can you
follow her but man i get it i mean if
you have student debt
and she comes out and say let's just
wipe it clean i mean i can see how that
message
appeals to younger people it's it's
unbelievable when you consider the cost
and then that's not even counting
textbooks
have you ever looked i mean they nickel
and dime these kids left and right
textbooks it's a 10 billion dollar
industry
10 billion dollars is what kids spend
you know what a 10 billion dollar
industry is
major league baseball that's a 10
billion dollar industry
gucci that's 10 billion every single
year
so it's staggering and you know
look at the salaries of the people that
run those endowments they're making
five six seven million dollars a year
insane from
1978 till today the price of textbook
has increased eight hundred and twenty
twelve percent kai what was the dow
jones ad
go go dow jones 1980. go down jones 1980
1980. is that what
880 uh let's say 891 and today's at what
29 29.649 what is the number there
i'm curious because if it's if it
matches
okay why don't you do this go to median
income 1980
median income 1980 1980.
is that what 21 336 and median income
today
hasn't got that much no median that's a
lower income class go to median income
so median income go a little lower uh
statistic click on that to see what it
shows okay right there right on the
below go a little lower to the bottom go
back
go back and go to the lower link right
there
stanford yep see what it shows us here
this is stanford
they're fairly reasonable 1980
income median income household
where is it showing that 1980 can you
see it is that about 20 yeah say 20. so
number's about right 20 000
and where's it at today 2020 go median
income so 28
1980 it shows median income around 20
what is 2020 median income it's like 46
is that what it was i think it's higher
than that median income
national median income right now 78 500.
so
78 500. so income has increased
give it 200 250 percent
from 1980 till today prices of books
have increased 810 percent how do you
keep up with that
i mean it's a business model right now
if you're selling text yeah totally and
i think it's a scam i mean what do you
even need books for
i mean my daughter's 14 years old when
she was going to school
everything's home now i i can't believe
how heavy her backpack is
and this is for a freshman in high
school college multiply that by
10. the the bulk of the books
everything's digital now
i think it's a scam to keep you know
hard copy books where you're hammering
the kids
for 1200 bucks it's unbelievable
who protects that industry democrats or
republicans
who protects that industry by the way go
back to that last stat
michigan university in uh minimum uh go
to right there let's play some numbers
1987. can you highlight that so the
viewer can see it 1987 michigan state
uh university the per credit hour rate
was 49.25
per credit hour assuming a full year of
30 credits amounts to 1
477 in tuition in 2017 the per credit
hour is 480 to 10 times more
with an estimated 30 annual credits of
460. 1987 is what 33 years ago
is that about 33 years ago 33 years ago
it's gone up 10x
in 33 years that's a lot of money right
there so who
protects universities is it more
democrats
independents or republicans i would i
would my hunch would be it's democrats
it's democrats that protect them a
little bit more because they're
preaching the language
they're basically preparing kids to come
out into the world to be democrats so i
would imagine that they if you had to
pick one of them
but you know these universities and this
whole college system
they protect themselves i mean they know
look at the ncaa basketball tournament
who gets rich off that the kids don't
you know uh
it's it's the universities that makes so
much money will muschamp
who was the head coach for south
carolina college sports terrible you
know
got fired this year they were like two
and five right horrible head coach
walks away with 15 million dollars i
mean it's just
colleges in general it's a house of
cards i think on some levels
and especially when when the world's
changing because of coronavirus
and what are they going to do for
tuition in the following years if you're
making kids do this virtually
how can you char they do they charge the
same amount of tuition
these private schools they're doing the
exact same thing but
you're going to see some things here man
because
there's a tipping point at some point
and you can't that's why this lockdown
is so bad anybody that thinks
a lockdown's good it's going to slow
down coronavirus that's what they said
last spring
and it didn't work it didn't stop the
curve it didn't do
anything so that's why i don't believe
this one will be effective and it's just
another way to give in to what they're
trying to do to you
and with no end in sight what are your
thoughts
education well my oldest son the doctor
would love to see this because when he
graduated med school he owed over four
hundred thousand dollars
you know i'm a cop my wife was a nurse
we didn't have the money to pay for his
college education not as not as
is it true that for the first 10 years
or so the interest rates are pretty low
and and are they kind of easy on these
kids or are the payments starting big
right out of the gate for them
well you do get uh a waiver until you're
uh gainfully employed
but uh you know his monthly uh
student loan payment is as high as his
mortgage payment
if not higher so i know he would love to
see this wave but
who you know the bottom line is who
bears the brunt of that who absorbs that
cost
if we waive all that the taxpayers of
course the time and where does their
money come from taxes right
so the ultimate thing is the taxpayers
end up paying for this
he understands when he took those loans
he had a responsibility to pay it back
he's okay with that i mean it doesn't
like making that check every month
but he agreed to that all the other
students agreed to that so why are we
waving that now
and another thing is if you go to the
just like you said the sports programs
i love college football i don't no
longer watch professional sports but
i love college football and i was scared
to death we weren't going to have it
this year
well it's such a big proponent of all or
a big part of all the colleges the major
colleges
we're all watching it again on the
weekends aren't we so
and then you look at the colleges
there's there's not a college that i can
think of that you go to and
hungry i were on the college circuit for
quite a while speaking to
major universities and colleges around
the country every college campus we went
to
had new construction ongoing you gotta
you can't you can't build things if you
don't have the money and when you look
at the numbers you just put up on the
screen holy cow i had no
idea it was that big what what is
elizabeth warren's plan
after you wipe out all the debt what
about the next generations of kids that
want to go to college
are they then taking out loans that in
15 or 20 years you wipe all that out as
well
i mean it's it's it's quite a rallying
cry to say hey let's just wipe out all
student debt trillions dollars i mean
it's unbelievable
again personal acceptance responsibility
you made an agreement when you borrowed
that money that you'd pay it back
pay it back but i i bet it's too high i
mean something has to happen here where
it can be a little bit more affordable
i don't i guess especially state
university i guess the thing being
becomes is it more
waive it and put the pressure on
taxpayers or put the pressure on
universities
or put the price there's only three
candidates here you got to put the
pressure on right three people here
one is the student who took on the debt
no one like you said it's responsibility
you knew what you were taking on when
you took that sally may
or whoever the loan is with right okay
is it their responsibility
is it the college's fault for charging
too much or
let the rest of the taxpayers take on
that one and a half trillion dollars and
say look we'll just pay the bill don't
worry about it
whose responsibility is it if you were
to put it in order
definitely not the government number one
i don't think i would say you you have
to start with everybody knows what
they're getting in for
right when you go to college you
understand when you take those loans
that that's part of you knew that
right so i would say that would be
number one and then
anything else i think would be gravy any
way you can help these kids if you're
looking at these staggering loans but i
don't think it's it'd be nice if the
colleges could find a way to do it but
they won't
well and when did colleges become a
for-profit company
oh that's been around for it is never to
this level no no doubt about it of
course never to this level
but you know you said you watch college
football but you don't watch
by the why don't you watch pros you said
you don't watch pros that's a whole
other topic
is it political um
i guess it is i guess it is it's i i
don't agree with you know
god bless these people you know they the
anybody involved in professional sports
you have attained the level of expertise
in a particular field
that most of us can't attain or we're
not dedicated enough to attain that
level
but the bottom line is it's a game it's
a game we can live without games in our
lives
for you to stand up and make political
statements out of of your
your fame yeah because you're a sports
figure i just don't agree with that
so is it fair to say you have a painting
of lebron james in your house somewhere
probably not probably not yeah okay um
biden
charity spent zero on research 3.7
million dollars on salaries charities
set up after beau biden dies
first reported by the new york post tax
filings viewed
by daily mail.com showed that the biden
cancer initiative amassed 4.8.
eight million dollars in contributions
but spent three million dollars on
salaries
gregory simon who super spearheaded the
obama administration cancer task force
was paired nearly double his 2017
earnings which was 224 000
the charities president received 429 000
in fiscal year 2018 the biden cancer
initiative spent nearly 1 million
on travel and conference expenses in
those two fiscal years
but zero on research how is that
possible you know it's just a bad look
if that's true which it probably is
that's a that's a lot of money to not
spend you know it's a lot of money to
take in but it's not
uncommon in the charity world especially
when there's high profile people that
run charities
i'll give him the benefit of the doubt
that he probably doesn't even know
what's going on with it
but it's an opportunity to take care of
some people like the guy who's making
400 000 to run this thing
i think you have to do something i mean
you're not going to save the world
with 3.7 million dollars with as big of
a problem cancer is
but it would be nice if you could attach
yourself to something especially as high
profile as the death of bo biden was
and as tragic as that was so i think
this is it's a bad luck
but what's worse what's worse this or
showing trump only paid 750 in taxes
the filing fee what's worse this or that
for them or the candidate what's worse i
mean
the view because look at look at the way
the viewer looks at it i'm looking at it
from the viewer the voter's perspective
one side here's a guy that's worth three
billion dollars and
he uh paid the you know 750 in taxes the
other one is
here's someone whose son dies creates a
charity raises 4.8 million dollars
and not a penny was spent on research
which ones i can answer that easily it's
way worse for biden and here's why
because his son died of cancer
and and to think that you're not doing
anything go do something else
you know honor him in some way but don't
start a charity for cancer research and
then not do
anything when your son died of that
trump we heard robert kiyosaki break
that down for us last week there's maybe
some loopholes
for guys like him to get around huge tax
bills
so i think this is worse and i would
agree in the fact that
are they buying political favor the
people that donated that money and
there's been no
research that's to me that's fraudulent
weird yeah it's wrong kind of weird to
me by the way if they
i mean again daily mail uk and new york
post
fair to say they're both extremely
conservative
uh of you know sites they're not fully
left or independent so people have to
know what side they're on it's not like
it's cnn reporting it or msnbc which is
far left
if they do report something like that
but uh that's interesting and that leads
me to
biden talking to hillary clinton for
potentially hillary clinton being on the
cabinet as the ambassador to the u.n
former national security adviser susan
rice said thursday that the reporting
president-elect joe biden is considering
hillary clinton
for u.s ambassador of the united nations
would be an insult to the former
secretary of state
meaning she deserves better than that
the thinking behind the move was that it
would be a way for biden to highlight
the importance of that position in his
administration
and that placing her there would rise
the prestige of the u.n itself at a time
when global cooperation and the u.s role
on the world stage has
ebbed the post-reported thoughts okay so
hillary's probably going why is susan
rice speaking for me i kind of want to
get out of the house
get away from bill i'll take any job in
the cabinet in the administration
uh it's wishful thinking he wants to
attach his wagon to hillary in some way
if this just came i know do you think do
you think
democrats when hillary lost do you
remember the media on the left when
hillary lost
they all slowly kind of took a step back
i don't know if you remember that or not
i mean there was a
there was a positioning from everybody
like for example
we're about to see it with republicans
look how many people today when they
said trump lost
everybody was waiting someone on the
right to come out and the first person
it took a day it was lindsey graham
saying i paid 500
000 to the legal nobody was saying
anything yes
newt was some of the but everybody else
stayed silent so
in a way republicans are also showing
their colors
they're showing their colors to say look
if trump lost we're kind of staying on
the outside now ted cruz defended him
but a lot of other guys are like if he
lost he lost right let's go and
you know kind of step away why bring
hillary clinton back is there a hillary
clinton audience for biden to want to
win over
well i think she's a brand and she's a
democratic brand and there's a place for
her probably in his administration
i think susan rice is saying something
bigger so i think she's validating the
fact that she should have an even bigger
role
such as so i know you're a big fan of
hillary that's why i'm asking you
something
a cabinet position you know something
much bigger than that and i'm not sure
what it would be
um she's already been the secretary of
state i mean she doesn't need to do that
again
but she's not just going to fade away
she has to stay relevant she has to stay
out there somehow
plus they're going to be taking this
victory lap for four years if they can
so everybody's going to be front and
center one day that would be a bad move
for them to take a victory lap for four
years because four years from now
biden's going to be 82
and i'm not sure in what state he's
going to be at 82
and if you do take a victory lap for
eight years and nothing gets done what's
going to be worse is in two years you
lose house
and if you lose house the way you do
then you're you can't get nothing done
because you're at gridlock
and so if you lose house and you don't
have senate then that means in four
years
someone on the right could potentially
come and take it away from you but
hillary wants to be involved i mean she
became a senator and went through
everything that you have to do to be
elected i mean she's not comfortable
just fading away
right that's i i have zero respect for
her
really yeah that's um
however and i still maintain contacts
with some of the special operations
units here in the united states and
just i mean the the incident that's
always out there has benghazi
and she could have saved people by just
making one phone call issuing one order
for a c-130 gunship to come in and save
those people
we lost an ambassador not just special
operators we lost an ambassador because
of that because the decision wasn't made
or the decision was made as a no-go
that's not your responsibility
your responsibilities protect americans
i don't think she's on the most liked
list when you think about politics if
you were to put right now
the most hated politician today
politician who would you put at the top
of the list
who would you run ahead of her oh you
mean on the democratic side no i mean
period left and right right
would you put trump one if trump is one
who's number two
probably hillary yeah because she's so
polarizing you think she's number two
i think so probably who's third left or
right who's third
most hated mcconnell pelosi i voted for
pelosi yeah mcconnell's not like title
by the way they're both on this but
she's just more high profile so i think
that she's probably got more haters
the other thing too is you know
everything's about favors at this point
you know so what whatever deal hillary
has in place already to serve
you know on some position she's got that
i mean she's gonna be there i know i
know you wrote an article yesterday on
vtpost.com
with freedom of speech being at the
question right now with some hate speech
where
freedom of speech they want to kind of
change the first amendment because to
categorize some things
isn't free you're not you shouldn't have
the freedom to say just anything
something should be categorized as hate
speech right so this is a member of
biden's transition team yeah that
uh has a media affairs job and he's
saying there's some problems with the
first amendment
now the reason that i believe that you
know this thing's not going to go
anywhere is because he's getting
from both sides you know so very
controversial thing but i think the
bigger picture is it's just another day
it's another radical thing that we're
hearing that they want to
potentially throw out there as a trial
balloon and see where it goes
or ultimately make a change they keep
talking about everything that they can
do on the first day it's frightening
when you start looking at that list
so look freedom of speech is there for a
reason there's a reason it's the number
one
you know bill of right so um
they would be in uh you know some
serious trouble if they tried to do
anything with that it's just not a
priority it shouldn't be something that
they should try to attack right away
let's let's wrap up with this uh uh not
every day we have uh uh steve here with
us steve
book how we took down pablo escobar tell
us a story that maybe wasn't in narcos
that's
another sick story because i know you
guys got non-stop stories give us a
story that maybe
uh uh uh i mean you know many people
watch
narcos pablo escobar series but have you
watched the uh
narcos series of el chapo did you get a
chance to watch that one or no no i
haven't watched it you haven't watched
it but you did watch this one
did penny watch the whole thing because
i know he said he hasn't watched the
whole thing of narcos
pablo uh i don't think he's finished it
and in narcos mexico i'm watched up to
the point where they're ready to kidnap
and torture kiki camarina and i haven't
watched past that nothing past that
got it so tell us a story about pablo
that maybe is not publicized but you
were part of it
oh gosh um
there's a well this is not so much pablo
but one of the original founders the
medium cartel is carlos later
who we know was he bought his own island
in the bahamas
which created a transshipment point with
a massive airway
which greatly facilitated moving cocaine
by a boat and by airplane from the
bahamas into the united states
we know that he was arrested when the
bohemians moved in and seized his
properties he fled back to colombia
he was eventually arrested there's
rumors that pablo was the one that
ratted him out
that led to his arrest he was extradited
to the united states and remember
pablo's whole battle against the
government of colombia in the united
states was extradition to the united
states because he knew
he would have to go to a real prison if
he came up here it wouldn't be
buying off the prison guards living that
lavish lifestyle like he did
so when carlos came up his attorneys
when they realized that they had an
airtight
prosecution case against him agreed to
cooperate we all know it's all in the
history books now
he testified against manuel noriega from
panama
well part of his plea agreement was that
the united states would agree to get his
family out of colombia
for safety reasons and very very
legitimate you know
i mean that that's dead-on because when
pablo would come to kill you
he just didn't kill you he got your wife
your children your parents
her parents your animals i mean he was a
vicious vicious person
i led the operation in which we got his
wife and children into a safe house
in bogota and then got him to the united
states
um a lot of people don't know you know
that's just some of the behind the
scenes things it's not classified it was
it's public record if you go look at his
plea agreement but that's just one of
the different stories that we were
involved with down there
one of the things that they left out in
in narcos that we include in the book
they show that my wife and i adopted a
little girl down there from uh
they show her being from medellin in the
show her name's olivia
well the circumstances show that javier
and i just been in this running gun
battle across the rooftops in medellin
unilaterally no colombian national
police that's straight out of hollywood
because we never did anything without
the columbia national police
we had that much jurisdiction down there
we had no legal jurisdiction
but then on the way back as they're
going back to their cars uh you know the
this
there's this little baby their little
baby girl and her dad was killed on the
air on the avianca flight when the bomb
went off
her mother was killed because they were
tying up loose ends and murphy and pena
come by and the actor says oh look that
little girl she's cute i'm gonna take
her home
even in columbia that's called
kidnapping you can't just grab a kid off
the street like that
you know so the truth is that we you
know we went through normal channels
right man talk about simplifying it
right i'll take her
yeah you know but what's that what's
good for hollywood yeah right what's in
oh they did a phenom i love the market
but
uh what they failed to put at the end of
season two was my wife and i actually
adopted a second little girl down there
so her
you know she is the first daughter is
from bogota our second daughter
from medellin that's very can i ask him
cool christian yeah did you know you had
a book in you when you were chasing him
did you know were you keeping notes
did you save evidence how did you write
this after the fact
no we didn't uh you know in our careers
all along people kept saying
hey you need to write you need to do a
movie you need to write a book that's
not why we did it we did it because
that's the case we were assigned to work
on
and people find this hard to believe
they said well after you got escobar you
know was your career over i mean did you
just coast the rest of your clear yeah
not in dea when that case is over you're
like hey big boy come here
here's your next case get to work on it
now that was a case of a lifetime we
knew that at the time but we didn't save
all this no i wish we had because we
could have made a little bit more
realistic
later in our careers and we've done a
ton of documentaries over the years and
when you work for the government you
can't make money on the side
when you work for the government you can
make money based on your job right yeah
as a dea
well you know any job i mean you have to
if i wanted i tried to run a little pay
phone business one time
on the side and i had to go to dea and
get permission and they said no
so it's funny though other people in
washington make money on the side
plenty we weren't allowed to by the way
if you lie
as a government employer you get fired
at least we did not every but that
doesn't apply to everybody right
so anyway uh i forgot where i was going
with the story because i got offered
another tangent there
no just how you saved all the notes and
had the yeah the recall for your memory
so later in our career a friend of mine
in washington is a small-time producer
and he introduced us to a couple of
producers that were interested in doing
something with the estonbar story
so i met with them one guy
i mean you know where the tea party is
on the right go past that
this guy is out there and there's a
story that that we were involved with
after the escobar investigation in which
we could have indicted the president of
haiti
jean bertrand aristide and it was
stopped by the white house
coming they didn't call us directly it
comes down through the chain of command
but we were ready to indict the
president of haiti
who was the president back then yeah
clinton yeah hillary's husband
and what's their foundation haiti
exactly
so he wanted to take that one thing and
make a political statement against the
left
well we're not about that we're not
about the politics and we just
we turned them both down we didn't think
anything would ever happen well that's
in 2013 is when eric newman
who's the creative narcos came along
nobody told us it was netflix till we
signed our contracts which
you know the price would have probably
been a little higher had we known that
but um the uh the book
was kind of an afterthought uh eric i'm
sorry to say patrick
eric is friends with a guy named luke
jenkins jinkler is our literary agent
jenkins desmond in new york city um
we're not writers i sat down one time in
my house when i first retired and i
thought
i'll write a book so i wrote for six
hours that day i read i got the next
morning read and i thought what a croc
i write like a cop you know so so
actually the author of our book is a
lady named isabelle vincent she's our
ghost writer
we spent uh over a year probably close
to two years
giving her stories telling her the truth
she's a fantastic researcher she works
for the new york post as a
investigative reporter she's written
four or five other books
she came up with the idea where we
alternate our stories back and forth
throughout the entire book and she did a
phenomenal job
so that's how that whole book came about
this is all after the fact
i love it congratulations on the book
congratulations on the success thank you
for
being a guest here with us folks we're
going to put the link below to be able
to go order man hunters paperback
just came out today the real story from
the actual dea
agents portrayed in the hit netflix
original series narcos is there a
picture
is is there a frame of that picture in
your house anywhere
office anywhere no nowhere you don't
even like seeing it
it's honestly it's disrespectful we got
caught up in the moment of
him being killed and uh you shouldn't
treat human bodies like that
so you don't like that you're not a
united you're not a fan of that picture
at all i don't shy away from it
every you know i was talking about our
speaking business we have over 75
appearances
a year worldwide speaking telling the
true story of pablo escobar
and that's one of the last pictures i
put up so i can explain to audiences
why i have that picture that's a picture
of javier pena
hanging on having a bunch of gold kilo
bars and rolex watches
my what is this here have your poses
with gold and stacks of cash seized from
an escobar safe house
in maiden during the escobar manhunt oh
the truth is that's how pablo
uh that's how javier came to work every
day he's got his bling on he's got a
gold plated at 45.
i can see that with javier by the way
javier's personality in the series is
classic being a playboy womanizer
left and right i mean he says he's not
really like that is what he said
well let's just say that might be the
one part of narcos that's really true
i'm joking i'm joking i'm here he's not
i love you brother uh we had a fan here
that just gave 49 bucks alden mahotovic
and put 49. it says plata or promo
you know because that's the famous line
and when it first gets started anyways
gang if you
enjoyed having our buddy or friend steve
murphy push that subscribe button we're
going to do this again on thursday if
you've not ordered this book we're going
to put the link below as well kai can
you make sure you put that in the
comment section
so folks can go order that and if you
are a nice guy yourself you may want to
add
the no more mr nice guy to the book when
you order man hunters watch amazon's
going to say
people who read man hunters also read
normal surroundings
the algorithms are going to be complete
i've got to write down in my notes
having said that thank you for coming
out and being a guest everybody i hope
you enjoyed it push that subscribe
button until next time
we will do this again when is it
thursday eight o'clock we're doing it
again
and for some of you that missed adam
adam will be back on thursday take care
everybody bye bye bye bye bye bye thank
you patrick
thank you
you